Hi, I'm Nazmul Idris,
a developer advocate
on the Android team, and welcome
to this episode of DevBytes.
In today's episode, we're
going to cover the new printing
API that was released with
KitKat, AKA Android 4.4.
Android 4.4 introduces native
platform support for printing,
along with APIs for
managing printing and adding
new types of printer support.
The platform provides
a print manager
that mediates between
applications requesting
printing and installed
print services that
actually do the printing.
The print manager
provides shared services
and a system user interface
for printing, giving users
consistent control over
printing from any application.
The print manager also ensures
the security of content
as it passes across
processes from an application
to a print service.
Most devices running
Android 4.4 will
include Google Cloud
Print pre-installed
as a print service
out of the box,
as well as several
Google Apps that
support printing, including
Chrome, Drive, Gallery,
and Quickoffice.
So what is this printing API?
Well, the print API
allows app developers
to write applications
that can print
any type of content to printers
that could be connected
over Wi-Fi or Bluetooth, or any
other kind of printing service,
for example, Google Cloud Print.
It also allows printer OEMs
to generate print services
and distribute them as
APKs on the Play Store
so that their printers will plug
seamlessly into the framework,
so that users can
print their documents
to any connected printer.
The system handles a transaction
between an application that
wants to print a document
and the services that
deliver print jobs
to an actual printer.
The print framework
provides all the APIs
necessary to specify
a print document
and deliver it to the
system for printing.
As an app developer,
which APIs you actually
need for a given print job
depends on the type of content
that you actually want to print.
For example, are they images,
HTML, or a PDF canvas?
In print-enabled
applications, users
can discover available
printers, change paper sizes,
choose specific pages
to print, and print
almost any kind of
document, image, or file.
Print services are
pluggable components
that contain vendor-specific
logic, services, and so on.
These are managed by
the system and are
responsible for discovering
printers, interacting
with them, and reporting
their state about what's
going on with the print jobs.
As a printer OEM, you can use
the print service framework
to provide interoperability
with your printers
from Android devices.
And this is really important.
You can build and
distribute these services
as APKS, which users can
install on their devices.
And they can be updated over the
air via the Play Store, which
is pretty awesome.
A print service application
operates primarily
as a headless service by
subclassing the print service
class, which receives
print jobs from the system
and communicates it
to printers using
the appropriate protocols.
The print services will get
printed content as a PDF file
and may apply whatever
transformations
they need to make to the data so
that it's optimal for printing.
And print services
have to implement APIs
for being queried by the
printers that they manage.
So now, from an application
developer perspective,
I will show you how
to use the print
API to quickly print content.
So for the broadest
compatibility,
Android uses PDF as its primary
file format for printing.
Before printing,
your application
needs to generate a
properly paginated PDF
version of your content.
And for your
convenience, we actually
have helper classes that allow
you to very quickly print
WebViews and also pretty
quickly create PDF documents as
well-- actually, PDF output.
So if your application knows
how to draw the content,
it can quickly create
a PDF for printing.
Now if you want
to print a bitmap,
it's actually very
easy to do this.
With very little code,
you can print out images.
And the only one option
you have to think about
is whether you want the
printed output to scale
to fit or scale to fill
the actual printed page.
So what's the difference?
Scale to fit makes
sure that your bitmap
fits within the maximum
dimensions of the printed
output page.
So with a square bitmap
on a rectangular page,
it actually results in
white space on the top
and the bottom of the page, as
you can see in this example.
Scale to fill, on
the other hand,
makes sure that your bitmap
is scaled to fill as much
of the printed output
page as possible.
And this might mean that
some portions of the image
are not actually printed
because they exceeded
the bounds of the
printed page, again,
as you can see in the example.
So here's some
code that shows you
how easy it is to
actually do this.
So again, the only
option that you really
need to be mindful
of is what parameter
to pass the getScaleMode method.
So once the printBitmap
method is called,
no further action from
your app is required.
The Android modal
dialogue box for printing
appears and allows the user to
select the printer and whatever
print options they want.
The user can then print the
image or cancel the action.
If they choose to
print the image,
then a print job is created,
and a printing notification
appears in the system bar.
Now let's say you wanted
to print some HTML content.
So here's some code that
will show you how to do that.
The first thing you do is
you can generate some HTML,
put it in a string, then
load that in a WebView,
and finally, attach a
WebView client to the WebView
so that once the content
is actually loaded,
you can submit the print
job to the print services.
So if you want to include
graphics in your HTML content,
just place them in the assets
directory for a project
and specify the path to
this folder as a parameter
to the loadDataWithBaseURL
method instead of passing null,
as we did in this example.
You can also load
an actual web page
for printing just by replacing
loadDataWithBase method
call with load URL.
And this is very convenient if
you actually have HTML content
that you've generated
on the server side.
Now there are a few limitations
of using HTML printing.
And one is you cannot
add headers or footers,
and this includes page numbers.
Also, the user can't
specify print ranges.
So for example, you can't
print page two to four
of a 10-page HTML document.
And also, an instance
of WebView can only
process one print job at a time.
And finally, WebView
printing from JavaScript
is not yet supported.
For example, window.print
JavaScript call will not work.
We are planning to address these
limitations in future releases.
And please feel free to
open Android open source
bugs for features that you
feel are important that
are missing or changes
that you want to see,
because this feedback
is very valuable to us.
So finally, there is
a PdfDocument class
which allows you to very
quickly generate PDF content
using the platform drawing APIs.
So this new PDF document
API offers a convenient way
for you do this by getting
a canvas object by calling
the getCanvas method
on PdfDocument.
Once you have the canvas, you
can draw your printable content
on it using the standard
graphics APIs on Android.
And when you're done
drawing your content,
you simply submit the document
to the printing sub-system,
and it'll just sprint.
So finally, this DevByte
has been a quick overview
of all that's available.
If you want more
information, we actually
have a training guide
called "Printing a Document"
on developers.android.com.
Thank you for joining us today.
Take care.